[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing a topic
that stimulates the minds of harry
potter fans worldwide
visiting currency now let me start off
by saying
that just because a wizard kind is far
more independent than muggles
able to achieve all sorts of things
through magic it doesn't mean that their
society can operate
without currency at the end of the day
the wizarding world
still has an economy of its own and
currency
drives this economy for those unaware
the textbook definition of economy is
a system of making and trading things of
value divided into goods
physical things and services things done
by people
it assumes there is medium of exchange
which
in the modern world is a system of
finance so
whether you're muggle or magical this is
crucial we also know that
just like in the muggle world the
wizarding world has an upper
middle and lower class within their
society the malfoys are upper class
weasleys are lower class and perhaps
someone like a middle-ranking hogwarts
professor
would be middle class this brings us to
wizarding currency itself
which is comprised of galleons sickles
and canards
in depreciating order these names also
bear
real world historical context galleons
were spanish treasure
ships often raided by pirates sickle is
the ancient greek term
for the shekel the currency of judea and
kanat or canute
is the name of an 11th century king of
england all of this currency
at least in the uk is overlooked by the
goblins of gringotts bank
so we've got galleons sickles and
cannots great
but those names also don't mean much
without financial context
so what are they worth to us what is the
equivalent
dollar value i live in canada but i
won't convert to canadian dollars
because most of you guys are either in
the us or uk
so i'll be providing equivalents in
those currencies
sorry to those of you whose currency
i've left out
to start one galleon the largest form of
wizarding currency
is said to be worth about five greater
british pounds
at least according to jk rowling this
would mean that the equivalent u.s
dollar value
is six dollars and 98 cents okay
so that's a start now what about sickles
fortunately we know that one galleon is
comprised of about 17
sickles so with an easy calculation we
should be able to find
the real world value of one sickle from
this
we can fairly confidently state that one
sickle is worth about
29.4 p in the uk and 41 cents in the us
next connects now once again because
we've been blessed with the knowledge of
wizarding currency equivalency
we can calculate the value of a cannot
one gallon is said to amount to
493 canads this means that one canard is
worth about
1.014 p and 1.415
us cents so now that we know the
approximate equivalent value of
wizarding currency
let's take a look and see what the
wizarding population pays for certain
objects
we'll start with some known prices when
harry buys the lot
all of the candy off the train trolley
in the first book it costs him
11 sickles and 7 cannots this means that
he paid
323.4 p in sickles and
7.098 p in canaan's totaling
330.498 p aka
three pounds 30 sounds like a good deal
to me
the equivalent in usd would be 460.905
cents
or 4.61 cents we know
that the ride on the night bus is 11
circles aka three pounds 23
or 4.51 this seems more consistent with
our own economy
albeit still a little bit expensive one
hot chocolate
is two sickles aka 59p rounded or 82
cents
for the same price you can get a water
bottle and a toothbrush or a butter beer
okay here's where things get a bit
expensive it has been expressed that a
copy of advanced potion making
comes in at a whopping 9 gallons 9
gallons
is 45 pounds or 62 dollars and 82 cents
given harry's immense wealth it's
interesting that he is the one who ended
up using a copy
from the classroom this means that a
lamborghini aventador in the muggle
world
would run you about 56 400 gallons
i think a vast broom is a cheaper option
and that's the end of this video
if you have any questions about
wizarding currency or anything else for
that matter
leave them in the comment section below
until next time
dry up jersey you big prune
[Music]